hey have you heard about Twitter's data
breach employees that are getting leaked
have you heard about LastPass data
getting breached have you heard about
Facebook getting hacked there are so
many news that we hear day in and day
out in this world and they are so common
in recent times we all know how big is
the scope of cyber security and it's
increasing day by day statistics show
that over 1 million job openings will be
there by the end of 2023
and the fact is less than 50 percent of
individuals are actually skilled to do
the job less than 50 percent and even
after the Advent of AI it's the same as
digitization increases more and more
people are coming online more and more
businesses are doing their business
online coming up with their assets
online after covert there is 600 percent
increase in cyber attacks and I'm not
kidding and there is a big fact check
that every 38 seconds there is a
targeted Cyber attack happening
somewhere in the world so what is cyber
security cyber security is an industry
where we apply techniques and tools used
to protect a computer related system
namely software Hardware or a network
from cyber criminals or hackers and
honestly cyber security as a whole is a
very huge field when people say about I
am getting a job in cyber security how
to get a job in cyber security if there
is no job in cyber security as such you
won't get it there are many Fades there
aren't many disciplines many domains
inside that so you need to to get a job
inside that because there are so many
systems divert systems that have their
own life cycle to secure for example you
might have heard about different types
of softwares namely web applications
mobile applications maybe Android or iOS
desktop applications iot applications
and many more for a job in cyber
security you can be a destroyer or a
protector you can join both the sides of
the coin for an offensive job you hack
and find bugs for a defensive job you
identify attacks and stop them and this
is a very high level simplification of a
cyber security job even if you go inside
red team and blue team there are so many
different domains like namely appsec
Cloud SEC forensic investigator SOC iot
malware analyst incident responder and
so on and the most common jobs you might
have heard about in cyber security are
pen tester for offensive jobs bapt or
red team and for defensive job it's SOC
SOC analyst or a dfr analyst or a blue
teamer and if I go in deep on all the
domains we will be out of scope for this
video I'm here to give you a general
overview of every domain and how to
create a career potentially out of that
and I'll give you a roadmap for the
exact things that you will do and you
should do I cannot tell you exactly what
to do because there is no perfect
roadmap for anything and I'll just give
you the bare minimums and my
recommendations what I would suggest you
to do so let's get started but one
problem I want to tell you but I can
tell you what to learn and how to learn
it but you'll need to find the resources
to learn because they're very scattered
there is no single course that can teach
you everything so the problem with
people is that they'll go there and
they'll find resources on Google they'll
learn from scattered resources and the
problem will be that they will not have
complete knowledge of the same domain in
deep they'll pick up voids between their
knowledge so it will affect their career
but what if someone shows you the exact
things to learn and make your industry
ready for a domain I'm gonna talk about
simply learns industry ready cyber
security program that will teach you
Indian find skills in just six months
and your career can be started right
away this program is Advanced executive
program in cyber security by simply
learn in collaboration with triple it
Bangalore where you will learn this
in-demand skills from their top faculty
with real world scenarios and here you
will learn practical knowledge by
solving practical Labs with popular
tools including necess and burp Suite
after the completion of your course you
will get a completion certificate from
triple it Bangalore in a transcript to
validate your learning apart from that
you will get a virtual internship from
npci National payments Corporation of
India in which you will get four
projects where you will have to solve
cyber security problems by identifying
issues or vulnerabilities in a system
and tell how to secure them sounds
exciting right so if you want to be
eligible for this program you need to
have a bachelor's degree at least and
one year work experience in any relevant
security field and some basic knowledge
of programming so if you are interested
then link is in the description go to
the link read all the description and
all the details click on apply now fill
all your details and just enroll right
away in order to learn cyber security
you need to First learn some
prerequisites it's not that easy to jump
directly into that so first of all you
need to love computers you need to fall
in love with them I am serious so first
of all the very basic skill you need to
learn is computer fundamentals so IO
input output software Hardware how
memory management is done Disk
Management memory Process Management
Windows and Linux in both the OS and I'm
not kidding you need to learn system
administration level of courses you can
do a plus and then you need to learn
virtualization 2 how to run an OS over
OS and multiple OS and you can find all
those courses on YouTube you don't have
to wander around anywhere and waste your
time everything you can get free so the
next thing that you need to learn is the
most important thing they want to talk
about is computer networking that's the
most important thing no single computer
can be hacked if it's not connected to
do anything else so there is no isolated
system in cyber security so you need to
learn how computers are connected the
basic PCP IP and OSI models and all the
layers inside that the most important
layers are data and clear till the
application layer so the application
layer is most important here all the
protocols that you will learn HTTP SMTP
FTP SSH and everything the most common
in web is HTTP so you need to be throw
inside that that is indirectly related
to internet internet runs on IP
addresses and port numbers so the third
and fourth layer are very important for
you to understand how network works if
you want to be a network pen tester then
IP IP layers and IP protocols and IP
types I had a formats TCP UDP port
numbers and all the details inside that
now repeat again 90 of hacking is based
on network so you need to learn them you
can learn from books there is some good
book I can recommend data communication
and networking from photosyn that I
personally used but you can watch
YouTube videos you can watch courses now
repeat again 90 percent of hacking is
based on network so internet is
networking the third thing is Linux and
shell programming if you don't know
majority of world's servers are based
out of Linux because it's robust some
examples for robust Linux servers are
rhel and send OS and even after that the
attacking machine that most of the
hackers use in the world is based out of
Linux because Linux is open source Linux
is robust it's customizable so you know
everything about it and you need to be
learning shell programming because even
if you don't have any tools with guis
you'll need to learn how to use them on
command line it's very important because
as a hacker you might have seen that
command line window a black screen or a
crane text so that's very fancy right
that is hottest terminal or a shell we
need to learn that to be cool just
kidding learning Linux is very easy you
can start from a beginner friendly OS
like Ubuntu it's very easy to learn you
can just explore and try things there
learn tools and then you can switch to a
hacker OS called Kali you might have
heard about it right many things so then
you can learn how to use tools because
it's made for penetration testers bipent
testers and there are many tools you can
you can Master you can learn the
techniques of hacking and it will be
very cool but first you need to make
sure that you're doing things right and
ethically and by shell programming in
Linux I mean Bash that's the current
standard of shell being used so there
are a lot of commands many simple
commands once you keep typing you will
remember in your subconscious mind lscd
PWD CP all of these commands will be
used in your daily basis and the next
thing is programming do we need to learn
programming many people ask me this
question is there a need I don't know
how to code I'm very weak in that but
I'll tell you if you opt for a offensive
job in a pen testing world you need to
learn how to program and how code is
written because in a corporate world
there is white box pen testing you get
access to the source code so you have to
extensively review the source code and
then find issues in that so there is no
way out eventually you'll need to learn
it but at the starting for a beginner I
won't say it's a big deal or a big
headache to conquer but you can keep it
on hold for some time just familiarize
yourself with cyber security concept and
once you feel you are ready to learn
programming on the side along the way
then you can just start it because
eventually you'll need to learn it at
the end so why not start early so it's a
very simple concept right how a software
is made what is it made of code right so
if you need to hack a software you need
to learn how it is coded how it is
written so you need to learn to read
code so you need to learn many basic
concepts of programming like data types
variables
conditioners Loops classes and objects
and these are enough so these are the
major Concepts that you need to learn in
basic programming and you can pick up
any programming language that you can
Master but you don't know which
programming language will come before
you to hack or test it can be anything
so you have to learn the basic concept
syntax are different in all the
languages but the basic concept is same
so these are the prerequisites that I
will recommend you to learn at the bare
minimum and these are very crucial so
once you get through all of them and do
brainstorming and keep everything in
mind and you've learned everything then
you can start go learn cyber security
from various sources because they are
very scattered and even then there is no
single course of cyber security there
are many domains many disciplines and
each of them have different things to
learn and topics and even here I have a
bare minimum concept to learn for you
all is the Avast top 10. so what is wasp
was is a foundation of web security that
is developed and designed for web
developers and security researchers to
make them aware about cyber attacks and
how they can secure themselves and every
three or four years they will release an
extensive list of top 10 vulnerabilities
or attacks that is the result of
consensus of all the issues and attacks
reported recently through statistics
and they have extensive Resorts Factory
for all of them including labs and tools
and they are all free so if you see the
list you'll see some examples like
Access Control security misconfiguration
secure design ssrf I'm not going to take
all the names but for each attack type
they have their own descriptive
documentation they'll make you
understand as a hacker and also as a
developer how you can see how we can
identify the issue in your code and how
you can fix them optimally and even for
all the issues there are Labs that you
can solve to practice them and realize
them in real world they have many Labs
including a wasp Juice Shop vivab you
can just set up them on a local machine
or just run a cloud instance and then
just practice them and even they conduct
conferences by the name of wasp they
also have their YouTube Pages you can
learn from them and they have a lot lot
of documentation they have a two low ASP
Zap for pen testing just like burp Suite
so they have very good resources and
I'll tell you one thing that practice is
the key if you learn a concept day don't
just leave it like that the theory won't
help you in getting a job you need to
practice the concept each and every
attack issue framework volatility you
need to practice them on your own
Hands-On with your own Labs so I'll tell
you that you know already that how
technology changes drastically every day
so you need to get updated and be
proactive in learning new things this is
a complete practical field okay and then
there is another resource just like
wasps there is another resource called
quartz trigger they have their own Labs
called Web Security Academy where you
can learn all the concepts of web
security and solve the labs online which
are free and also they have a tool
called burp Suite that's the most
popular tool that every hacker uses when
they want to pen test something so even
I use that even you will use that
everyone uses that and every Cyber
attack has an impact and a risk involved
in that there is a huge difference
between us and impact that's where our
risk and compliance things come into
place the risk management there is a
different job profile file called GRC or
governance risk and compliance with many
other names but the concept is the same
that you find an issue but how to fix
that and how to fix the risk the risk is
associated to the business the risk and
compliance team will relate every risk
to the business impact or objective so
the basic goal of cyber security is to
identify and realize your risk and then
to contain it and reduces as much as
possible that's where hacker come in to
realize those risks and if I talk about
defensive jobs their job is to learn
digital forensics and incidents so they
need to learn how to do Incident
Management how to review the logs how to
use Siem tools and how to correlate data
so they'll have to find evidences of all
the attacks that recently happened and
continuously monitor the network events
and create alerts so that they can
respond to them so they have to do a lot
of Investigation correlation and root
cause analysis of the issue once they
find the route or the culprit they'll
try to reduce the risk and prevent them
from happening in the future so likewise
we have many domains and each domain has
its own deep knowledge that you cannot
gain that's not possible you need to
select a domain of your choice you can
only get by research pastel study no
College can teach you that but I'll tell
you one more problem I told you
everything that you need to learn you
learn everything you gain all the skills
you do a lot of practice that you know
that you know everything that you can do
and perform those attacks but how will
you tell the HR how will the HR know so
it's not just about acquiring skills
it's also about proving your skills
that's what happens when you look for a
job when you hunt a job look for a good
career the first thing is to build your
resume professionally that's the short
listing criteria you won't even get to
the interviews if you don't take this
seriously so I'll tell you what all
things you'll need to add in your resume
so the first thing is degree
unfortunately you need to do a degree in
CS or it Branch because most companies
want that and my preference score of
degree is b-tech then BCA and then BSC
but if you are a maths student the
b-tech is the best option if you are an
art student then you don't have any
choice you can do BC or BSC if you are
from any other Branch like electrical
mechanical civil you haven't done
bachelors in CS or it then you can go
for Masters you should go for Masters
but I won't say it's very hard
requirement or a very necessary thing to
do I didn't do Masters myself but if you
want you can do that it will be a good
option for a job if you're getting good
placements in that college but I'll tell
you that the degree is the only thing
that we require we don't care about
anything else and how you do it you just
need that certificate so you can do
private programs distant learning
anything doesn't matter the second thing
is projects they are very important as a
fresher specially because you don't have
any work experience so you need to do
something apart from your learning so
whatever you learned whatever skills you
gained you should apply them somewhere
to prove it like that's the point so you
can apply our cyber security skills with
any other domain like AI Cloud security
blockchain web3 include anything combine
them and create a good project with many
project ideas that I can give you and
then you need to open source that
because you need to show the employer
because they will demand and require
your link that they can verify
themselves because there are many false
alarms out there and I've already told
you how you can do projects in cyber
security that simply learn internship
from mpci from that advanced executive
program will give you four projects
that's all you need that's all you need
to put so you can put that link in your
resume along with your LinkedIn that's
equally important and the next thing is
certifications and I'll tell you that if
you do a certification then you don't
need to do a master's degree at all it's
not required do some good certifications
because they teach you a skill in a
particular niche in deep in a shorter
time so it won't take you two years it
will just take you one month two months
three months or maximum six months if
you are good enough and there are many
certifications right now in the market
that you can choose but for India for an
HR I think ceh is the most basic
certification that they look because
they all know that but skill wise eh is
not good it's just a theory Examination
for practical skills for actual skill
development you should give oscp because
HR loves it and also you will get a
better job with a better salary and a
better company with oscp because it's
more skillful and more better than CeX
folder and also the problem is with oscp
is the price that's why not many people
take it it's more costly but if you want
to be cheaper and gain some practical
skills too you can do e-learn
certifications like ejpt ecppt or eccpd
you can correct me ewaptx those are very
practical and very good certifications
not on the level of oscp very close to
them but still they are cheaper so it's
a good deal there are more
certifications that are more relevant in
outside countries like Security Plus pen
Test Plus crtp so that you can do that
if you want to plan for some foreign
countries or foreign jobs so likewise
two three certifications are more than
enough and now comes work experience the
internship I've already told you how to
get an internship just go to the simply
lens program and you will get it just
enroll there so that's not a problem for
you but if you want extra internships
you'll go to the LinkedIn create an
account today you'll need to be actively
involved in LinkedIn and don't use any
other social media more than LinkedIn
because it's going to help you in your
job search the most so connect with
people do an internship at least three
months or maybe six months it will gain
your good experience on how work is done
in an industry and then even that
company itself can give you a job offer
called PPO and you can join with a good
package or a salary so now your resume
is strong enough you can actively look
for jobs and that too it will be the
same in LinkedIn so you need to build as
much connections as possible with good
people working in a good company in your
desired cyber security domain connect
with HRS and approach them talk to them
personally share your resume be
professional be polite be kind
and make sure that you reveal a sense of
passion inside you and building a good
Network in LinkedIn helps a lot you will
get a lot of referrals if possible if
you don't know what referral is is you
can just get into a company with a trust
of another person that's already working
in that company and getting a referral
makes your job hunt much easier you land
a job much easier because you'll get
interviews and even if you make some
mistakes in your interviews it will be a
trust Factor they will be tolerable and
they'll select you and for a job hunt I
have seen people talking to me coming
back saying that they are not getting a
job they've tried hard enough but when I
ask them how many companies you have
applied on they say only 5 or 10 that
doesn't make sense you need to apply at
least 50 to 100 companies because the
average reward rate is 10 so if you
apply in 50 companies you will get reply
from five of them so that's the rate and
keep that in mind try hard as you can so
when your resume is shortlisted you'll
have three to four technical rounds with
a managerial round these are the average
figures and if you are applying for an
offensive job like a pen tester you'll
get you'll expect OAS top 10 and code
review questions definitely and scenario
based questions are a very common and
good companies today because they'll
have to test you on a hypothetical
situation how you handle the situation
what is a decision-making approach and
how you solve the problems in very
stressful environment how you can work
under stress and don't even lose your
composure and calm in those situations
so the technical skills are not enough
you need to have some soft skills like
communication skills listening skills
decision making skills and always have a
growth mindset I'll tell you one simple
key to getting a job in cyber security
is to understand the risk of your assets
and learn how to contain them and adapt
to the ever evolving and changing threat
landscape cyber security is an Ever
evolving field its scope is not going to
get declined anytime soon it will just
keep improving so the only problem with
people is that they don't learn
consistently so you need to learn
consistently and be aware of all the
technological updates around you and you
should be good so all the best for your
next cyber security job that's all I got
for today and don't forget to enroll
into advanced executive program that's
the flagship course that will make you
industry ready in cyber security along
with an internship so that's all for
today thank you for watching